rated M for Mature  don't know if everyone will agree with  everything I did to get all this  together don't care it's done  looks like someone's freaking paranoid  or something you know they won't let  their secret leave this island  save it  yeah  talk where am I  I promised that I would let the world  know our story our story of what  happened here on this island Nara Pella  and I'm getting the story off the island  I'm just not sure I will why you should  want to get this story quits dad is  gonna publish it worldwide  well I met someone so who the hell are  you he knows a lot about what's  happening here figured you needed you  kind of call me young minute anyway my  name is cliff Calo he's my story